we are a lot of us a great deal sadder
more anxious more incomplete and more
Restless than we really need to be
because of something very large that's
missing from our lives what's worse we
don't even know what this thing is and
how much we crave it because we don't
have the right concepts experiences or
encouragement to help us locate it what
we long for and are slowly dying without
is community they tell us that we're
suffering for all sorts of other reasons
because we're afraid of intimacy or are
low on serotonin are beset by anxiety or
chroma or are chronically dysfunctional
around attachment or trust these may be
accurate enough descriptions of our
symptoms but they arguably leave the
real causes of our miseries untouched to
come to the point it's worth holding on
to a basic historical insight for most
of our time on this planet by which one
really means for 99% of Homo sapiens is
evolutionary existence we lived in
communities that is groups of 20 or 30
people who worked together cooked
communal meals and lived and died around
each other for most of history we'd
watch the Sun going down with the same
people we knew deeply trusted sometimes
bicker with but overall felt
overwhelmingly connected to we'd shoot
the breeze we'd comfort each other when
we were sad we'd drop in unannounced on
one another's quarters we'd chat over
our pains and stresses and at special
moments we'd dance together and
occasionally fall into ritual ecstatic
states where the normal barriers between
egos would dissolve it's only very later
on in history that we've started living
in condominiums commuting to work in
offices with people whose values we
don't share and eating for one in cities
of 10 million strangers of course
arguments from evolutionary history
aren't always useful for most of history
we've suffered from chronic toothache
and didn't have access to hot baths
but no one would argue against our
abandonment of our natural state in
these areas nevertheless holding on to
the idea that we were once tribal and
now most definitely are not can help us
to put a finger on something that we may
legitimately miss and urgently needs to
recover a semblance of what happens to
us outside of life in a tight-knit
community well firstly we get very
concerned far too concerned with falling
in love in love with one special person
who we're told will end our customary
sadness and provide an answer to all our
social needs unsurprisingly this
enormous pressure on what a relationship
should be is the single greatest
contributor to the collapse of unions
that might with more manageable
expectations and a more close-knit
Friendship Circle be entirely viable we
end up having to throw a lot of people
away when we want them to be that most
cruel of things everything secondly the
very pressure to be in a couple means we
bolt into relationships that should
never have started and stick far too
long inside toxic situations out of
terror of singlehood thirdly in our
alienated condition the desire for
connection can morph into a longing for
extreme success Fame and renowned we
grow materially wildly and insatiably
ambitious out of an unquenched emotional
need for nothing more esoteric than some
good friends even if we do have some
they're liable to be scattered around
the world cocooned in their own
relationships or unavailable to us most
of the time we've let our terror of
intruding on one another scupper a yet
more precious need one for an atmosphere
of mutual assistance finally our picture
of what that nebulous category other
people is like grows very somber because
we meet one another not in person but
via the media something which constantly
gives us cause to believe that other
people are fundamentally extreme
dangerous and
even though we collectively pride
ourselves on living in highly innovative
times we remain absurdly traditional in
thinking about our social setups we have
a million new apps a year but no one
ever seems to seek to reinvent how
people might live together sadly but
understandably communes don't have a
good reputation one thinks of religious
extremists weird fanatics and messianic
leaders none of the genuine advantages
of bourgeois life or simply of recent
existence seem compatible with communal
living furthermore everything legal and
commercial seem set up to frustrate any
wish to live together land costs a
fortune building is only for the very
brave or the naive and how would one
work who would do the laundry what would
the neighbors think nevertheless it's
worth pushing the imagination a little
and sidestepping some of the practical
hurdles for long enough to get the mind
working the material questions can
always be solved once an idea properly
takes root so imagine for a moment what
it would be like to live in an ideal
kind of community it might be an elegant
set of buildings in a desert or on the
edge of a forest everyone would have a
room 20 or 30 in all modest but
dignified laid out amidst an array of
charming communal areas breakfast lunch
and dinner simple and nutritious would
be eaten in company at long tables there
would be a commitment to look after one
another
and fellowship based around shared
ideals and values the craving to get
ahead would subside it would be enough
just to be accepted by this kind group
this would be one's tribe to whom one
would open one's heart and entrust a
substantial part of one's life we'd have
a joint sense of what meaningful work
was and some of the most important work
would be offering one another
reassurance we might have partners but
we wouldn't expect them to be everything
a chance to share thoughts and emotions
with other people would take a lot of
the pressure off couples we'd have a
daily impression
mattering to others our impulses to
addiction power and paranoia would
lessen we'd rarely go online the point
isn't right now to have an exact
blueprint for a commune but to wake
ourselves up to our desire for one after
which anything can flow
our ancestors were unfortunate in a
thousand ways but they may well have had
something that we are unknowingly dying
for their own tribe
our perspective cards feature tools for
a wiser karma perspective on life they
help to restore calm and clarity even
during difficult times